there's four or five single actions you
could take
to actually
impact your own
health and longevity so at that point
we've changed the entire game of one of
the biggest killers in humankind so stay
with me now because this is a little bit
all right we're diving in this is it
richard rossi in the house
oh my god he is how you doing man uh so
nice to see you
joe polish at the end i don't did you
know that of his challenge that he
created which one are you referring to
okay so at the end of the annual event
there were four ten minute talks
you were one of them
he issued a challenge to say
uh i want i want people to take action
by the end of the year on
one of the 10-minute talks
oh and we're doing a competition i think
i'm the only one who picked yours i
bought the book like right away
you know i was watching you talking like
this is amazing this is great yes yes
what's the next step so i need some
homework as to like what i can do
before the end of the year to uh it's
kind of a hard thing because it's a
lifetime
but what can i do before the end of the
year as uh homework
cool
and um how old are you 41.
okay excellent i assume and there's
something about
my talk that rang true to you um tell me
a little bit about
what you heard where you went oh yeah
so
one just
living living longer is i think is a
good thing
um just in general i'm not i'm not one
of the ones like okay you know what when
i'm 80 then it's over and i just my time
is my time i want to be able to serve
for as long as i can um and then two
just to have a
not just length but quality of life
as well um it was
kind of crazy timing because when that
when this book came in
my grandmother passed away
so when i started this challenge you
know she she passed and uh and listen
she had she had a it's the things we
always say i guess she had a long life
she was in her 90s um the last decade
though were kind of this slow
decline to the point where it's like not
really a life by by the end of it and uh
i want to
avoid that
[Laughter]
myself and haven't just kind of seen it
um
i was i was fascinated by your talk to
say hey how can i
how can i be a
if i can't live forever then at least be
a kick-ass 100 year old
right okay fantastic and are you married
yep have a wife have a son
how old's your son
12.
okay excellent
so
and do you have parents that are alive
yep both alive
okay are they like in their 70s or
yep early early 70s um
that's great too
okay so here's the thing what we're
going to talk about isn't just about you
it's about your parents it's about your
spouse it's very much about your son
and it's also about you
but the information that we're going to
discuss today
can profoundly affect all of them
to the degree that they are willing to
take a leap of faith and realize that
things are possible now that weren't
possible years ago okay
um
and what i mean by that is that uh there
are
that
the way people remain healthy now
involves what i call the big four
which is stress control nutrition sleep
and exercise
and yet there's no
evidence
that that will actually extend your life
what it will do is it will
make the years you have much much
healthier
and that's and vibrant and vibrant is my
key word you know i want to be vibrant
mentally and physically
so
the how do i know that you know how hell
do you know that richard well i know
that because there are no
hundred-year-olds walking around who
look and feel 50. there are no 90 year
olds walking around who look and feel 50
despite the fact that there are a
massive number of people that work like
hell on the big four
and have for decades
and the reason is for exactly that
that that's not
going to extend your life however
that is what i call the foundation of
everything we're about to talk about
and i'm going to use the metaphor of a
house
the foundation collapses
doesn't matter how pretty the house is
the foundation is in fact the big four
because you want to build on a
foundation of strength and good health
when possible
the less that you
need to fix up the better
so that's the huge role that the big
four played it's not i'm not poo pooing
it i'm not saying it's not in poorer and
it's critical
but above the big four
up until about five years ago there was
nothing there was no first floor there
was no second floor there was no third
floor
uh and the reason is we didn't have a
damn idea
how to actually affect what mother
nature is doing to us so
when you get to be about 35 years old
that's when the decline begins
so there was an interesting line from
hemingway's book
the sun also rises where they asked one
of the characters how he went bankrupt
and he said slowly and then quickly
and that's exactly how you decline
slowly and then quickly
and that decline starts slowly and
um
and almost uh
you know completely silently around the
age of 35.
um and
there's a list of over a hundred things
that i could
give you
and i'm happy to provide that to you
that start to slowly go down
but they're almost imperceptible in the
beginning and you feel like a million
bucks and if you're really great at the
big four you continue feeling like a
million bucks but that doesn't mean that
those things aren't happening and
they're you'll learn about those in the
book they're things like um
your epigenome and your telomeres and
all and
and the strength of
your stem cells and all kinds of things
that are mostly invisible
but are happening to you right
we have a few people in da vinci 50 who
are even younger than 40.
and they're geniuses i would never have
a million years
thought about doing something like this
in my 30s because i would have said i
feel great i'm young
well that's exactly the moment of
maximum opportunity because the older
you get the more you have to kind of
reverse things that have already gone
wrong
which is another thing that we can do so
let's be real clear first of all in our
objective our objective
is age reversal it's actually being able
to show objectively through biomarkers
and other things
that
you're getting younger
and the reason we we use that as the
marker is that you're absolutely right
to prove age extension would take
decades and decades and decades
but to show that you know your heart's
getting stronger your blood work is
getting better that your hair is growing
back
that the the enamel on your teeth is
regenerating
that your eyesight is improving that
your lung capacity is going up that your
sexual function isn't
super increased there's a million things
that we can show that actually go oh
this is the x of a younger man
and that's what we we that's what our
objective is to show that those things
are going back in time not forwards in
time
and
now
we begin to have tools on the first
floor
a few not a lot
but a few
and those are in david sinclair's book
they include stem cells they include
a drug called metformin and we talk
about all this
there's another drug called rapamycin
these are
safe drugs that have been on the market
for decades
and
they just we've just now discovered that
they also have properties of age
reversal
and
then there's the second floor and the
second floor is what's coming in the
next two three four years
uh
and
there are incredibly remarkable things
uh that are we're right on the cusp of
right now incredible things in terms of
regenerating uh body parts organs fixing
things
and a whole bunch of other
interventions that can actually move
those biomarkers back so just keep
thinking biomarker biomarker biomarker
right the more biomarkers you have that
you can show you're getting younger
the younger you're getting right
and then the other part of the first
floor
is
avoiding things like cancer right some
of which is hereditary
um
and there are is for example the new
blood test that we're just getting
access to this month out of india that
detects every cancer at stage zero
so
for example
if i said to you do you have cancer the
only honest answer would be i don't know
um
but with this blood test you will know
uh and it will identify if the if you do
have cancer where in the body it is what
kind of cancer it is so the objective is
that you do this testing every six
months or a year and if there ever is
cancer you catch it when it's so tiny
that you just knock it out so at that
point we've changed the entire game of
one of the biggest killers in humankind
which is cancer and the older you get
even if you are moving your age back the
more susceptible you become to things
like this so this is why we need to
catch it and snuff it out quickly
um
so then we have the the second floor and
that's coming in about five to ten years
and that's going to be modifying your
gene gnome okay so you're lucky you have
at least one grandparent that lived very
long
that means you have at least a partially
great genome
but we will now be able to actually do
that in a in a thoughtful manner and can
take out things
that um are causing you to age and there
are people that are doing that right now
um at harvard and mit they're doing it
with pets
and
they're doing it successfully
and the other way that we measure your
your
age
as opposed to your chronological age
is something called um
there's a certain type of blood test you
can do
that gives you your your
if you will your epigenetic or
biological age
and i'm throwing some buzzwords at you
but i'm trying to just make it as few as
possible
and
i can right now
expose you to a therapy that will move
your biological age back
um it's a stem cell therapy out of
california there's a company that
that called true age that
has been working with stanford and
harvard and mit and all kinds of
incredibly
legit people
and is able to actually measure what
your
biological age which
sometimes is identical to your
chronological age but as you can imagine
if you've been smoking all your life or
doing fentanyl or whatever it's probably
you're probably older than your
biological age and vice versa well this
is a type of stem cell treatment that
can actually move those numbers back
that's actually on the first floor
that's available now
but only to people who can afford it and
are in the know but it's measurable and
that's what we're always looking for
that's a key word you need to remember
measurable i'm not interested in what
happened to joey and mikey and sami and
all those other people i want to know
what happened to me and i want to be
able to measure before and after and
actually see
a objective measurable impact of
whatever intervention is going to take
place
so that is really the long and short of
it it is
it is creating a so i would say the
absolute uh foundational elements and
i'm gonna shut up and take your
questions
are number one
as i mentioned at the end of the talk
don't die and everybody laughs like
that's hilarious but it's true you know
don't die of something stupid and don't
get so sick that you're beyond help
because the really
the stuff that's going to keep you alive
an extra 30 40 50 years that's not
coming for another 10 years or so so you
want to get as much on the foundation
the first floor and the second floor
it's got you aging backwards that's got
you in great shape so that when like the
genetic stuff comes you're
really ready for it and in good shape
the second thing is
to
take advantage of what is available now
and i would say the third thing is to be
is to
honor those big four and realize that
you do need to
stay in really great shape and catch any
problems
incredibly early uh
but
i will tell you that there are a lot of
people who say and you know this because
they're in our groups they go i'm going
to live to 120. well how are you going
to do that
well you know i have big dreams and i'm
going to stay in great shape and i'm
going to have lots of you know and they
give you all this crap and you're like
you realize you would be the first
person in human history to do that if
you actually pulled that off you'd be
the first person in human history and do
you think you're just going to do it
through those things no you need you
need a big hammer and lots of them
because mother nature is not that's not
what mother nature has in store for you
so if you can actually
make those changes you have to do them
using
techniques that will not be available to
the general public for decades for a lot
of the reasons that i outlined in my
in my talk and we can go over all of
those in detail
the reason i asked about your son
is because your son
through your knowledge will have the
ability to never get sick
to never get a chronic disease
to
instead of declining
when he reaches that age of 35 he's
going to float
and he can do that because there's going
to be that intersection of
what you've taught him and what he's
doing
and what science has got available and
what you're going to have access to that
maybe his classmates won't have access
to for 20 years that's going to make his
life span 150 180
you know like incredible
so
i always think about the whole family
unit when i think about
a traversal
and i'll say in in i guess my final
thought is you have to surround yourself
like with people who believe this
because
if you
go to a cocktail party with your wife
and start talking about this people will
listen politely and then when you turn
around they're gonna go
you know there he goes again he's insane
so you have to be actually surrounded by
a community of people that can support
you and believe what you believe and
help you and you help them
end of uh end of
of speech i love it that's great man i
could i could listen for for a long time
um does all that make sense it does look
i'm on board uh i'm on board with the
thesis i don't understand the science
i'm i'm diving in and trying to figure
it out i better move it will really help
i i mean i bought it i'm about
a fifth uh maybe a third of the way
through it now um i was i was
drowning in the science at the beginning
of it a whole bunch of terms that i
don't understand but you know i'm making
my way uh and
up until this point in the book it's all
about the i think probably the big four
um and i'm doing it so now i'm fasting i
eat two hours a day uh
every day of the week um working out six
days a week with the focus on getting
the heart rate up so it's not just a
yoga session um just started doing the
cold stuff every day
cold shower all that stuff um what else
have i done i'm basically applying i
read something then i apply it and i'm
filming the process of me doing it to
hopefully get some some kind of results
um what
what
do you recommend
me doing to be able to show because i
like documenting this and hey let's
let's show the world what what's
possible through a at least a use case
of one
is my next step to to go to true age and
get this measures done what do i do next
well i'll give you like the cheat
shortcut um if you just have the ability
to throw money at this problem um
so there's one guy that is in our da
vinci 50 group by the name of jeff
gladden
and jeff is a by professional
a
cardiothoracic guy
but about 10 years ago he switched to a
life extension and now age reversal guy
he's a genius and there's
a lot of people that we both know
like dan sullivan and folks like that
that actually use jeff
i've used jeff
and
he creates a program for you that is
aimed directly at age reversal
and
he
it's an n of one it's created
specifically for you it's executed
specifically for you it's monitored
specifically for you
um
so if you just want to jump in the deep
end of the pool and say
i'm ready i want to do this
and you know i can throw money at it
and i'm talking like a hundred thousand
dollars
um
then
jeff is definitely
your guy
if that is not the direction that you
want to go
then i could make
a list of other people who could be
guides to you
i'm not that person i'm more a student
like you are i'm just a little further
down the road than you are
but um really great anti-aging docs
that could um get you in motion right
now
um and for less money than that um
considerably less money than that where
do you live
toronto canada
okay well it's not going to be in canada
i can grant hear you that's okay i can
travel okay
um
so
that would be the direction i would go i
mean like if you want to show action
well then you need to start doing the
right things for you and i'm not the
person to guide you there you need
because every person is different and
everybody needs something specifically
designed
for them
if you just wanted to take one action
that could have that would have a
significant result
or you wanted to get in at a
lower price point
um peter diamandis you know him right he
and tony robbins have started uh two or
three
um anti-aging clinics and i was with him
uh in august and it looks like they're
pretty good um
the first one is uh i think in florida
um
but uh that would be a cool thing the
other thing is like there's this guy i'm
actually going to go out and see on
tuesday who does um the stem cell
treatments and you could actually
measure your age like if you just wanted
to say here's one really cool thing i've
done right now well this was my age
before my stem cell treatment this is my
age after my stealth some stem cells
treatment you know i had this problem uh
whatever that might be
now
the stem cells helped reverse that
problem so that would be so there's four
or five single actions you could take
to actually
impact your own
um
your own
health and longevity and show that
you've done it
who's the stem cell guy
so his name is dr todd ovakitis
and he has invented
something that is like so mind-boggling
uh that i actually david sinclair who's
kind of the leader in the field i was
talking to david i introduced him to
todd he went to todd and he's like todd
you're going to win a nobel prize for
this
so basically
so stay with me now because this is a
little bit
all right we're diving in this is it
all right so stem cells is a really big
deal
and they they um
are designed to fix things
that's why they exist
and to also lower inflammation in the
body which is great
um
and
when before we're born and up to the
time we're born
we have a massive number of stem cells
called embryonic stem cells and they're
doing they're like the worker bees that
are building everything and
they're they're they and they can create
and build and fix anything
we lose those the day we're born
um but we still have a ton of stem cells
in our body
um and they can be extracted
previously in one of two ways either
through
body fat which you look like you have
extremely little
or
um through bone marrow ouch
but he and he has invented a way to
extract it from blood
and
not only has he figured out how to
extract it from blood
but
they are the closest stem cells to the
embryonic stem cell they're the most
potent
they can change in in in into anything
in in theory fix anything
whereas the
the stem cells from muscle sorry from
fat or from bone marrow
they they're limited in what they can do
and what they can fix
um
so
what he does is he extracts blood from
you
um a few tubes does his magic on them
spins them and
whatever else
and then he reinjects it into your body
and here's the magic part
he uses a patented laser
to actually direct the stem cells
where they're needed the most
so let's say just for example
that your mom has kidney problems
you know her kidneys aren't functioning
at 100
well he would aim the lasers at her
kidneys so that all those beautiful
embryonic like stem cells
would assemble themselves at the kidneys
and work to start fixing the kidney
right if you didn't have that the stem
cells would go wherever they feel like
on oh maybe your mom's got an infection
in her big toe well they all decide to
go to her big toe right so you can't
direct stem cells unless you have a
method of doing it and he's invented a
method of doing that
um
and
so he's moved my age back three or four
years so far
and he's also
cured a
a inherited thing i've got
actually on my hand
that um is incurable it's not a bad
thing it'll never kill you but it's it's
um it's a genetic
call it a malformation
and
after he applied the laser to my hand
um i started seeing
the
these little
calluses
just start to disappear
and i showed it to my doctor and he said
you realize that can't happen
this this goes one direction the wrong
direction and there's nothing that can
stop it and i'm like well guess what
so
there's there is some magical magical
things going on out there
i would rather you
take uh
you know you become you become the
world's expert
on and you're like a complete genius
in your area
the question is are you willing to take
the time
to become an expert
or at least bring in a team of experts
on this
for you for your parents for your wife
for your kids
it's a really really really big deal but
it's all below the water surface now
and if you're not willing it's like the
early days of anything you know
you got to be willing to learn about it
assemble it yourself play around with it
know who's in the know
that's the stage we're at right now if
you're looking for turnkey then you've
got the the um
peter diamandis
group and i get you the name of them and
i think they're they're solid
um i haven't evaluated them myself but
they seem pretty solid
and then there's individual people like
jeff
gladden who are
just you know bleeding edge on this kind
of stuff so i guess my question to you
is like
you still feel great
you still look great
and
yeah there are things happening inside
your body right now but
for all intents and purposes you are
great so the real question is how
motivated are you
a 60 year old is damn motivated let me
tell you because they're seeing the end
it's not that far away
but
you are not that you know you've got a
lot of runway
so how motivated are you
probably not as motivated as you know my
parents would be or my grandmother you
know would have been if she had the
option the day before but i think
pretty pretty motivated for someone my
age and probably older than me um
and i think it's
one again learning from me
but also be able to give it to other
people and for all the people like you
know like if i can learn this and help
my parents not have the same fate as my
grandmother that's a pretty big win and
if i can then bring that to the world
through content i'm always trying to
make meaningful content
to inspire right everything i make is
hopefully inspirational positive make
the world a better place not the
negativity and why you can't do things
um i think i see this as kind of a next
frontier so
um
i guess the actions you mean the actions
speak for themselves at some point
somebody can say they're motivated but
they until they do it i did pick up
lifespan the second you said it you know
then i reached out to you and here we
are so i'm i'm open uh whether
i think i'd love learning for myself but
then also to expose it and and shine a
light on it and be able to reach more
people than
um otherwise
it could to bring it from below the
surface to you know slight slightly more
above through my audience
um
yeah so if it's if it's jeff or peter or
todd or
or somebody else
i'm
i'm i'm excited for whatever the next
step is
well i will tell you that
it takes
a special person
to
to to take this on at your age
you know if you have high blood pressure
and you don't treat it
you're good for 20 years
you know that's the slow part and then
it's going to happen
and that's the fast part
um
if um
if you smoke
you're probably good for 20 years
you know so you're in that phase where
you're good for 20 years but there are
things happening
and if you have the wisdom
[Music]
um
to
to take action now
you'll look back 50 years from now and
go
i'm a genius you know because you'll be
the guy
that needs to make new friends when your
old friends are all dying
um
because you you took action you took
action
uh
i'd hate to be the person that looked
back and said i could have done it but i
didn't do it and now
i'm debilitated and
you know i'll tell you
so i've been getting over a really bad
case of sciatica which is when the nerve
of your leg is inflamed and it's pain
like
it's hard to describe how painful it is
and it's been going on for several weeks
getting better now but
and i realized you know when you're sick
like that
it could be cancer it could be lung
disease it could be neurological it
could be anything
all your dreams go away
instead of being focused on creating
value you're just focused on yourself
all of your
all of your energy
and creativity goes away because it's
all absorbed in the pain you can't be in
great pain and be creative at the same
time
your world becomes so small
you lose track of days
because you're just managing your
situation day to day minute to minute
and you're not living your normal life
it's horrible
and if and and
it really to me
it it
was
even more of a wake-up call that i never
ever want this to be my fate
um
when i'm alive i want it to be in
vibrant good health
how often are you doing the stem cell
treatments
what's the recommendation
it's definitely not one and done um
you can the the the average
is once a year
uh or once every two years
i actually do it three or four times a
year which is the maximum you can do it
because i'm i'm older
and i i really want the maximum effect
so i'd say you know for someone like you
once a year would
you know be
totally adequate let me just give you a
couple of resources right now what do
you say
for and youtube is fantastic and i have
a little newsletter so if you go to
longevityage.com
you can subscribe to my free newsletter
and what happens is when i see an
interesting
article i just tag it and then we put it
out on this little newsletter it's all
free if anybody wants more information
on what we're doing
it's the
davinci
50.com
i appreciate the time man and this is
the start of beautiful things
well i tell you what i really feel like
my role is also to communicate uh
to the world so
i'm hoping that um
there's a lot of stuff that that that's
possible and some of it might involve
uh both of us you never know what the
future holds but i'm excited to just
um get you going so yeah you'll be
hearing from me very soon
cool man thank you appreciate you okay
take care bye
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with deepak chopra check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
every thought you have
is a magical lie
how do we live a life with zero physical
or mental weakness
loneliness comes from the fear